bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fa vj e oggi siamo
su penombra di nuovo eravamo rimasti che
c'era questo nostro amico bellissima tra
l'altro che avevo lasciato felice sul
tavolino e schifo bene e poi è chiusa
dall altra parte ma noi non ci ha fatto
sto pezzo a si vede che non ha salvato
abbia tanto non c'era nulla da fare la
prima mente devo ammettere se mi ricordo
bene il foglio foglio di giornale che
sta qui da qualche parte ci stava un
foglio di giornale non mi ricordo dove
beh ragazzi siamo partiti non mi ricordo
più
allora lei va detto
ci stava hoc per foglio sta qui altro no
non mi ricordo se c'era altro no
perfetta la devo mettere foglio qui
sotto il software che poi devo spingere
la chiave giu devo tirare il foglio se
prendere la chiave aprirà la porta e
[ __ ] perfetto
non lo so perché mi e ripassi perché
ovviamente come punto di salvataggio mi
dice anche ragione allora eravamo sì
eravamo rimasti che c'erano sì cosi
bellissimi sul muro
praticamente a furia di cercare di
trovare aveva scoperto una cosa epica
che era questa
sembra ok sembra la musica del finale di
lost tipo però è praticamente sono
simboli sul muro di certe fortorina
mente deviata ma va
la cosa che dovevo fare qui era a
segnare sul suo foglio mi sono segnate
un appunto non si sa mai praticamente
alla luce degli ultravioletti si vedono
le scritte su quel pezzo di carta sul
foglietto c'è scritto password del
magazzino 1371 ha la password del
magazzino sarebbe quello che ok ok raga
ci siamo abbiamo finito praticamente
abbiamo che cazzo vuole questo stai
zitto non ti voglio sentir come noi
ragazzi questo è uscito di testa da un
bel pezzo è questo quello che non ci sta
più con la testa dunque dicevo possa far
stai zitto mi fa il favore di stare
zitto anche nel caricamento parla parla
ovunque si senta va bene comunque
adesso capitoli farei monologo tanto io
ho smesso di ascoltare la metà a metà
penombra perché tanto diceva cazzate nel
foglio bianco c'è scritta la password
che tra l'altro mi ricordo spero si
possa leggere è praticamente la password
serve ad aprire la porta l'ultima che
rimasta e poi oltre quel punto non so
che cosa c'è e l'ultima cosa che è
rimasta da fare va bene noi andiamo
avanti
il cane ancora non l'avevo fatto fuori
evidentemente no praticamente una volta
aperta quella porta non di vedere non mi
vennero non mi vedere non mi vedeva
niente
[Musica]
yes vabbè dicevo una volta aperta st
porta qui non so proprio che cosa c'è
perché era l'unica porta che minima
nell'aprire questa poi io ho aperto
praticamente tutto quindi l'unico punto
per proseguire è effettivamente questo
penso perché oltre questo non c'è più
niente allora la porta è questa il
codice qua qual era il codice sì sì però
devo leggerlo come cazzo lo leggo era
137 qualcosa
1372 tipo no era 137 qualcosa non mi far
tornare lì come cazzo lo leggo ottica
quando forse nelle note può essere
quella pagina a passar 1371 mi chiamano
male eravamo sbagliato di un numero 137
ok
fuck yeah meno male che c'era scritto
laga perché veramente non mi ricordo di
nuovo un po ma perché sono tutti uguali
sti cazzo di posti
non importa sento porca [ __ ]
anche qui anche qui no anche qui no non
mi rompete le palle già prima me l'avete
rotte che la metà basta terremoti non me
ne frega la prima porta affini porca
[ __ ] quando riprende vero
boh raga io non mi faccio capace di come
sia possibile che non mi abbia visto ma
va bene
cazzo succedono salve ok adesso mi sa
che mi ha visto
ok perfetto mia mi ha visto mi ha visto
perfetto
[Musica]
praga è sparito è sparito ma va bene
così sono male
noi andiamo avanti non so dove sono
questo nuovo caso questo sta continuando
a parlare da uno da un ora parla che
cazzo sai da dire ma no no quasi nervi
lo ammazzo solo trovo lo ammazzo
ho chiuso ovviamente ci mancherebbe che
trova una porta aperta la porta
sigillato non si aprirà mai più e quella
dell'altra ok allora quella conduceva ad
altra stanza e va bene raga io qua c'è
mica il cane no in sti postino non mi
trovo cioè non so più dove cazzo sono
del tutto chiuso poi prato si infatti
quando giusto strumento quale fessura
non ci siamo quale fessura
c'è una fessura che si è probabilmente
inventato che però non lo so la l'ha
vista solo lui sinistra non c'è niente
non c'è niente non c'è niente bene
non c'è nessuno
ok in fondo in fondo sinistra a caso va
tanto raga tanto ormai sto andando a
casa da destra porta chiusa tutto chiude
cazzo cazzo non mi vedono mirate mia di
spegnere spegne la luce 20 la luce
vecchi non come chat resiste
[Musica]
questa ragazzi me la devo scrivere non
ci posso credere non mi ha visto mi
chiama ce ne deve essere proprio corpo
ma orbo forte cazzo è cioè non mi ha
visto un metro e mi vede a due
chilometri non ci credo no infatti non
mi ha visto perfetto pieno di cani sto
cazzo di posto
quella è rimasta l'unica via problema
che è occupata leggermente come potete
vedere no non mi sta vedendo non mi sta
venendo sono tranquilli fa solo finta a
meno che io non riesca a tutti può
sì sì sì sì
no cazzo ma come ha fatto oddio su
permesso cane corri no no no no aiuto
aiuto mio dio mio dio ragazzi non ci
credo come cazzo fatto che succedono
che cazzo succede cos'è un altra cosa
le voci qualche [ __ ]
corri corri sigit dai sì sì sì già fatti
e sigillata non lo sfonda non la sponda
nola sfonda cazzola sfonda corri corri
corri messico dio mio santo no cos'è ha
toccato l'acido bene
l'acido non lo passa a verona non lo
basta l'acido non lo past reso morissi
io chiudo tutto si può andare a fondo le
poche mio dio
dai dai dai dai non ci credo
mio dio ok no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no non ci passa non ci
arrivo non ci arrivo
oddio no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no cutie chiude dai
no non ci credo
apcom io uscirò prima parte prima che
quella energia tedesca raggiungermi si è
bloccato si è bloccato ok ok ci siamo
quasi
ragazzi scoprirla per me perché sto
sfruttando un bug megagalattico il il
verme ancora di fermo che incastrato nel
muro appena pro devo chiudere
immediatamente c'è come cazzo faccia ci
dovreste a porta poi non lo so però
vabbè ce l'abbiamo quasi fatta
ce l'abbiamo quasi fatta dai da esso
ci prova mai si chiuditi però no no
entra questo oddio non ci passa non ci
passano ci passano ci passa
sta passando
fatto salvo la partita
raga questo è un bug assurdo
non ho mai visto un bug così grande c'è
ragazzi questo è uno dei bug più assurdi
che abbia mai visto
probabilmente non doveva andare così ma
va bene lo stesso cioè finché è ancora
li senti facciamo così riguarda
stronzo lurido
mi fai schifo facciamo così
aspetto
adesso fai più o meno il colpo di sole
non so se hai presente
ecco goditelo
biava
ok non si è fatto niente perfetto non è
rassicurante come cosa poi viene di
composti chimici raga non so che cazzo
mi servono ma tanto non mi raggiunge
bene
fa piacere ok ma non c'è niente che
possiamo prendercela comoda tanto è
bloccato ma ti piace sta sedia
i bianchi dove cazzo va
si sta mangiando la scala yo yo
bloccherei giusto anche se penso che una
scatola non farà la differenza blocco
perfetto
bene
composto juan e cassetti c'è quel tanto
ormai carne essiccata non penso che mi
piace al barbone ultimo cassetto
perfetto non c'è niente
ho controllato tutto si tanto ormai tipo
li è fatti
io vado
continua a mangiare la scala
bene mi piace sfruttare i bug non so
come è stato
raga non mi chiedete come è possibile ma
sono riuscito a sfruttare un bug epico
bene ho trovato un casino di composti
chimici non mi chiedete che cazzo me ne
devo fare di sta roba
però ha qualcosa ma qualcosa doveva
servire credo è veramente che non ci
siano ancora passato perfetto meglio
stiamo andando da qualche parte che non
so neanche io tanto dei composti che non
so che cazzo mi sento il momento cos'è
sta roba
entriamo in una prima volta che mi
capita tanto ok non mi piacciono le
grotte
perché mai una porta dovrebbe condurre
qui dentro che cazzo ammesse sono gli
scavi
non c'è niente di ostile vero no perché
l'ultima volta che sono entrato in una
grotta
c'è uno zainetto con un foglio
testamento di giò freeman come al solito
ragazze qualcuno di voi vuole leggere
stop i video perché io non leggo come al
solito cose da fare dov'è alla ricerca
di rialzi di ton o per trovare precisi
indizi a perché ci sono i resti
giustamente inutile ma non del tutto ci
sono rasetto e un paio di antidolorifici
perfetto ok è sì così servono a qualcosa
non penso quindi andiamo avanti mio
addio quanto è grosso
[Musica]
siamo in antartide a ma volendo quella e
l'uscita però non so come arrampicarmi
fin lassù salviamo la partita intanto si
si tanto ormai questo è andato fuori è
andato in volta nello stesso tempo non
capisco guerra non ti capisco anch'io
una baracca in disuso chissà quanti anni
ha o chi l'ha usata che cazzo serve
scusa
sembra esistente ma non come arresto di
certo non ci camminerò sopra ok come
questo dovevo dargli ascolto mi sa
la morte un terreno inesplorato sì mi sa
che ci ha ragione bene e allora come
cazzo perché che vada magari cazzo
ok
mi sono salvato non so come ho fatto
tratto qua c'è anche un passaggio quindi
questo non dovrebbe crollare no bene
scusate ma se io faccio tipo così
madonna ma dopo ok ok allora si può
attraversa io non pensavo si potesse
attraversare bene allora prossima tappa
devo riuscire ad arrivare lassù
ok
ok raga impossibile se non so come
faccia d'arrivo all'osso che ci provano
cos'è quella roba lì c'è qualcosa da giu
lo vedete ma ci vado se riesco a no ok
evidentemente meglio di no ci vado dopo
buy sì sì sì sì gun l'ultimo raga
l'ultimo ci provai ok fail
ok ok al solito
vado su questo che più resistente
perfetto cessa roba qui raga che non mi
chiedete che cazzo c'è un braccio non ho
la forza necessaria per sacal e piede di
porco da questa mano congelata questo
quanto in gore tex è molto professionale
moderno spero non ci sia ancora un po
staccato gesù che razza di situazione
bene e allora lo stacchi così bene bene
non si stacca ragazzi non si stacca
perfetto cc da fuoco ci siamo
che schifo lo dovevo immaginare che
doveva segar libra cioè piede di porco
la mano mi serve ma io me la porto lo
stesso perché mi è simpatica e mano
andiamo torniamo indietro forse utile
per una passeggiata nella tundra già
inciso un nome freeman morgan
praticamente non so dove andare la gara
non sta ma non so che cazzo farmene
vabbè io tornerei indietro no ok
okay dai c'è qualcosa da giugno non c'è
niente vero perché non poi non vado da
nessuna parte formali che era sono muore
all e ci siamo ho un piede di porco non
mi chiedete a chi cazzo mi serve la
porta per l'inceneritore bloccata con la
treccia battuto riuscire ad aprirla
allora la fessura la fatidica fessura
che abbiamo trovato prima dovrebbe
dovrebbe riuscire ad aprire dovrebbe
riuscire ad essere aperta con la roba
col piede di porco che mi ha appena
trovato se il cane ci fa passare va bene
non me ne frega niente anche se mi vede
prova a passarci lo stesso che si vada
classico che si curino maurice prossimo
guardatelo lancio d'arancio capiti
qualcuno ha la minima idea di quello che
è appena successo
meglio non lanciato lui e mezzo svenuto
per qualche secondo si speriamo sia
andato a destra perché io ho fatto
andare a sinistra
torno indietro perfetto
l'uomo io ok cazzo la porta la porta se
si infila telo in fila però ok ci siamo
ci siamo ci siamo come uscire appena mi
dica cosa
ad aprire la porta l'inceneritore che
dove all'inceneritore dovendo
l'inceneritore avanti avanti avanti
avanti a destra ok ci siamo ragazzi
siamo tranquilli tranquilli calmissimi a
presidente
pole
porca [ __ ] ma che cazzo succede c'è bel
posto tra l'altro fantastico questo
passaggio non esisterà più tempo maretta
o qualcun altro ci hanno chiuso i buchi
con delle assi di legno perfetto perché
il presentimento che il vermone si farà
risentire fosse successo questa deve
essere a galan di quelli mas
intrappolato reddy devo trovare un modo
di demolire tutte ed in fretta ma perché
voi liberarlo quello stronzo
fammi capire quale sarebbe l'utilità
trovarci 1 deficiente in mezzo ai
[ __ ] che mi ha fatto passare dove
c'erano i ragni non me lo dimenticherò
mai
non me lo dimenticherò mai mi ha segnato
quell'esperienza è la c'è una mira
assurda ragazza
ok perfetto apri minchia non riesca la
piena porta tv di perché non mi piace
come zona modali magari qua dentro c'era
perché c'è un caso che esplode questo
senza andrà benissimo per la miscela di
composti chimici e il libro sugli
esplosivi darà una mano allora i
composti ce li ho già li ho presi prima
con quel bug è piccola tolgo sta roba
che tanto c'è luce finalmente una stanza
illuminata non ci posso credere
va bene
i composti tv cos'è sta roba da miccia
perfetto il cosa devo fare
contenitori di vetto salviamo perfetto
raga siamo per liberare il maniaco
dovevo preparare soli composto chimico
che tra l'altro o scaffali vuoti non è
che c'è qualcosa qui dietro no si
perfetto no perfetta allora cos'è
bruciato perché una bomba chimica e se
non sono mai stato bravo in chimica raga
ma proviamoci allora bene dov'è il coso
raga però non so io non ho la più
pallida idea di come crearla sta roba
ok devo per aprirla devo non lo so cietà
nati o no non capisco cosa devo fare
cioè allora filo cosi a caso bene mi
serve del gas per accendere bruciatore
11 piante in cui miscelare i composti
chimici e il recipiente cielo e questo
si cela
ok allora gas è aperto
e aperto
[Musica]
scusami su giustamente se no perché io
volevo riscaldare ovviamente le sostanze
solo lo gas comunque allora uno questo
costa questo no questo con questo no
questo con questo no
ok raga praticamente sono tornati tutto
indietro dove c'era il vermone le prime
ti avevo dimenticato una boccetta che
era la f
e tra l'altro tra l'altro ho trovato
anche questo
allora prima e magnesio secondo calcio
terzo barrio 4 cloruro quinto il fosforo
e del sesto del sodio il problema è che
a meno che non siano le iniziali credo
aspettate un attimo mcb cfs non sono
iniziale perfetto è il problema che non
so diciamo non solo ordine quindi devono
comunque come prima andare a caso
all a caso dovrebbe esserci possono
aversi attentamente martin e si stabile
ha detto ah ho capito
e allora poggi un secondo a terra porca
[ __ ] non era non era appoggiare vabbè
a una manca a miccia amici cibo no io io
la porto c'è ma devo dapporto
direttamente dove ci sono le macerie
ok raga allora io la porto lì però non
so se devo attivarla con la miccia o
devo lanciarla non l'ho capito tanto io
la lancio se esplode bene se non esplode
invece ci metto la miccia e va bene da
io adesso siamo arrivati ci prova
vai a troy esploda va bene ma che cazzo
no no no no non ha senso
ero lontano un chilometro mi spiegate
come ho fatto a prendermi c'era non ha
senso mi chiamo mi devo rifare la strada
che palle taglio raga ok ok ok raga
allora facciamo così
ha fatto tutto lui questa deve essere ok
mi sono segnato un appunto non si sa mai
cosa devo fare
individuate le macerie che bloccano il
passaggio red ora devo trovare il modo
di rimuoverle perfetto
miccia no con la ricetrasmittente lo
stava accendendo per perfetto
vai via via via via mia via via via via
via via via via
ok non crollerà tutto
siamo vivi red ci sei devo darti tante
di quelle botte o conservato il piccone
red red per mezzo c'è una porta con la
luce led te ne sto per dare tele stop
che cazzo red sei tu
mio dio
così non riesco mi sarebbe cosa per
farle mi sono ha segnato un appunto non
si sa mai che cazzo succede individuato
la porta chiusa non è che mi ha indicato
red devo riuscire ad aprirla la apro la
pro con cosa la pro ci sarà qualcosa
magari tieni un po di carne red tanto
essiccata spero che sarà mangi così
almeno minchia si muore
comunque ha forse piede di porco
chiusero idraulica non si aprirà mai
forse se togli essi la corrente andiamo
le varrà corrente red stai tranquillo
che prima o poi arrivò non pensare di
scamparla stai tranquillo bloccata cazzo
bene raga non si apre la porta quindi va
bene a me qua ce l'ha non c'è il
corrente che cazzo ne sta roba
[Applauso]
sì se cosi non so che cazzo servono
immondizia è un posto tranquillo a
differenza degli altri permesso anche
qua siamo nel punto di sopra di questo è
vero
[Musica]
non cerco risposte voglio solo darti una
picconata sulla testa
tutto qua se tranquillo c'è poi da te
stesso io credo che mi vendo e il figlio
mi segnalò per chi paga questo qui è
ufficialmente andato in volta però a sei
lì dentro bastardo ci penso io ci penso
io in quello che fai ti preoccupare
lucidati ci penso sono qui per questo
ma o si guarda se inviti per un tè anche
me ci penso io ci metto cinque minuti ma
neanche proprio una botta e via
che cazzo è questa e una croce
va beh
indicatemi graziate per terminata fuori
città di gas perché reggio vuole che lo
uccida perché così cosa posso fare
ucciderlo ucciderlo non c'è bisogno di
perché devi farti problemi quando poi
ucciderlo tela anche chiesto gentilmente
io perché dovrei non dovrei esaudire il
suo desiderio dai
[Musica]
è finita
ok va bene e ha una chiave
red come tutto a posto
alla fine la piccola tela devo dare
perché trovo promessa però diciamo che
hai avuto la fine che ti sei meritato
per avermi mandato dai ragni io non ho
avuto nessun problema a esordire tuo
desiderio diciamo comunque bene ragazzi
abbiamo raggiunto il nostro scopo per me
io sono già contento così
ho trovato una chiave cercava si nazioni
che cosa davvero voleva proteggermi da
cosa aprista porta ok va bene ci siamo
ragazzi a carne essiccata perfetto ok
concentra la chiave per l'altra porta
perfetto scusatemi perché ovviamente
questo non aveva la serratura vi siano
anche giusto perfetto mi cercava di
proteggermi dai libri perché i libri
fanno male se ti arrivano in testa
infine shakespeare salviamo ok
sembra che nemmeno fatto cenno a coppie
di me stesso di verona non si vabbè ho
capito non ha mai smesso di ascoltarti
cos'è sta roba
che schifo raga ma si è pisciato addosso
nel materasso se pisciotto a letto non
lo so però c'è un armadio c'è un armadio
che cazzo è sta roba
decisamente mese davvero affamato che
schifo è ma cos'è
oh mio dio ma c'è ma è un ca o
e qualcosa non ho capito cosa però va
beh c'è un microfono
adesso mi metto a far commentare in
penombra bene il cassetti si faccia
qualcosa qui mio carissimo amico come
sai io sto bene tuttavia delle tristi
notizie qualche giorno fa c'e stato un
cedimento da parte alla struttura
superiore
raga
non ho letto nulla fino dall'inizio
quindi non ha senso che lo leggo
comunque come al solito
se volete leggerla stoppate perché io
non leggo specialmente roba da scritta
scritta da sto deficiente comunque abele
sito nuovo viste
ora hai trovato la pace cece sito d'asta
io la facessi tranquillo allora facciamo
un bel commentari siediti no se ci si
possa senza sedia senza sedia riesco a
vedere red seduto qui a win a guidarmi
non sarei qui adesso se non fosse stato
per lui perché ha lasciato perché mi ha
lasciato qui da solo veramente non avrei
visto i ragni se non fosse stato per lui
avrei preferito morire prima però vabbè
che cosa devo fare qui cosa che cazzo di
posto a cena porta più nuovo vi sta bene
wow mi devo impiccare o cosa
bene non prosegue niente dopo questa
stanza ma a parte sto buco che non pensi
mi ci devo ficcare dalla puzza questo
forse la sua caminetto io purghe detto
coletto proprio così bene larve ecco
perché era affamato che libagioni russa
quante aveva trascorso con il collo in
queste capi accettando di farla finita
non me ne frega niente non me ne frega
niente c'è qualcosa che dietro si perchè
se no non posso più proseguire un quadro
elettrico un posto simpatico dove
metterlo staccati
cosa devo fare lo so perché faccia dopo
tranciare
ah ok lo svitato perfetto ok
l'elettricità che arriva fino a ok
perfetto allora tagliamo la e ci siamo
perfetto mi impicco prima comunque raga
siamo per avvicinarci alla porta
definitiva credo perché non c'è più
niente dopo quella non posso proseguire
e l'unica porta l'unica via di per
proseguire il gioco
e vabbè ci siamo ragazzi mi sarebbe cosa
per fare ancora ma se l'ho aperta l'ho
aperta l'ho aperta con acqua che è il
perfetto
ok non aveva capito quando sono entrata
nella struttura sotterranea ci sarebbero
dovute essere domande paura e dubbi sì o
che del posto una bella nota lusia
rifugio popolazione fondazione persone
comando in preparazione 57 documento
d'identità ok è una specie di bunker di
sopravvivenza che cazzo ci faccio in un
bunker di sopravvivenza
c'è una roba qui va bè uscita se magari
chi cazzo è quello c'è qualcuno laggiù
raga
aspettatevi
sì
che cosa succede oggi a prima porta
apri la porta a porta
apriamo al condotto condotto condotto
chi cazzo è quello non c'è più raga e se
lo slider è sparito non c'è non c'è
certo era lì l'ho visto sono ancora
chiuso ma te che cazzo
finché caso che cosa sia successo
[Musica]
e qui che era finito l'uomo scelto per
il primo in questa miniera ed è qui che
inizia il mio prossimo capitolo
continua maiga
ho finito penombra cioè è stata ragazzi
una tortura una tortura
mi avete de mi avevate detto che
penombra questo era più spaventoso del
sé quello vero black flag che era quello
che avevo iniziato che sarebbe il sequel
di questo praticamente inizia che io
sono appunto in una stanza non so come
mi risveglio ii è in penombra black flag
ci sono proprio i mostri veri quelli che
fanno veramente paura
non in questo mi avevate detto che in
questo faceva più paura è quindi l'ho
fatto per questo ma invece faceva molta
più paura all'altro e poi l'ultimo è
amico come siano all'ultimo penombra
comunque sono contento di averlo finito
anche perché veramente ci saranno
veramente dedicando troppi episodi
sono contento appunto di averlo finito
va beh che dire raga ditemi se volete
che faccia black flag
io sono contrario sta cosa però va beh
se proprio volete fatemelo sapere più
avanti magari lo farò
vedremo un po se mi riprendo da questa
per per un po la faccia una pausa la
penombra perché non ce la faccio più
però se vi piace veramente tanto posso
provare a farlo voi ditemelo
[Musica]
o se vi è piaciuto il video come al
solito lasciato mi piace un commento qui
sotto
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
trovate sempre nella descrizione di ogni
mia vita
se non siete iscritti iscrivetevi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]